so we'll start our five headlines our
five-ish headlines with what may be what
may be maybe the cringiest corporate
virtue signal of all time and I realize
that's a bold statement I understand
they're competing with some real Heavy
Hitters uh in that Arena uh you know to
make a statement like that the cringiest
corporate virtual signal of all time I
mean you're you you're in the arena now
with Bud Light the reigning Champion but
I think it may uh emerge Victorious with
this so first here's the article from
Business Insider
it says you might be surprised to learn
that's uh to learn there was a Jeff
Bezos cameo in Star Trek Beyond you
probably missed it his face was hidden
behind an alien mask after all not to be
outdone Apple CEO Tim Cook acted
opposite Oscar winner Octavia Spencer
Sans mask in a surprise skit during
Apple's big iPhone event event on
Tuesday Apple held its fall event
wonderlust on Tuesday where it unveiled
new products including the iPhone 15 and
new Apple watches uh this year's event
however featured a rare skit on Apple's
sustainability initiative starring cook
and Spencer who also stars in the Apple
TV drama series truth be told
um now okay before we play the clip so
this is their event to roll out the
iPhone uh so that we're on the iPhone 15
now which I mean it's a cliche at this
point to point this out but it's also
true that this thing is exactly the same
as the iPhone 14 which is exactly the
same as the iPhone 13 and the 12 and the
11. I mean this is this is and it's
relevant too because to what you're
about to see because this is a company
that is totally out of ideas
um they have not had
like what was the last interesting
exciting
Innovation that we've seen from Apple
it's been a very long time they've had
they haven't had any interesting ideas
in many years uh so the pitch for every
new iPhone is basically just hey
remember the iPhone you have right now
well you should get this one it's
exactly the same
if you like that iPhone you have now
well then you'll love this one because
it's literally the same phone
um so there's no innovation here there's
nothing new I've mentioned before Ross
douthit's book from a few years ago
called the decadent society which
outlines his theory that we aren't we
aren't really we're not exactly
collapsing as a society it's not some
big dramatic collapse that we're
experiencing he he says uh but rather we
are languishing in decadence and by
decadence he means that we are uh
Treading Water we're going around in
circles repeating ourselves we're just
we're just out of ideas
and the constantly updated iPhone that's
no different from the iPhone before is
just a perfect example of this
and this means that Apple has to look
for other ways
to get attention and to make themselves
seem fresh and I guess to try to
incentivize people to buy their products
and uh that's where this skit comes from
let's watch a little bit of it
but we didn't keep you waiting
Mother Nature
Mother Nature welcome to Apple let's cut
to the Chase and 2020 you promised to
bring Apple's entire carbon footprint to
Zero by 2030. yes we are in the process
of eliminating all plastic from our
packaging by the end let me guess 50
years from now when someone else is left
holding the bag by the end of next year
actually electricity status we're
operating on a 100
I think we've seen enough uh so that
goes on for like five minutes and first
of all I know that I've I've been
skeptical recently about the concept of
toxic work environments but if you work
at a place where you're asked to
participate in a skit like this then
that really is a toxic work environment
I mean you need to get out of there
that's traumatic I don't know if the
other people in that sketch were actual
Apple employees or if they were actors
but either way it's horrible
yeah let's not be distracted from The
Uber wokeness I mean the wokeness on
steroids on display here this is this is
what we've come to okay this is this is
what it's come to with the corporate
woke virgin signaling a Company CEO
groveling to Mother Nature
represented by an overweight black woman
the only thing they're missing when it
comes to the woke bingo card the only
thing they're missing is the LGBT tie-in
and honestly I mean like I said thing
goes on for five minutes I haven't
watched the whole thing so maybe they
throw that in there somewhere I I they
must I'm not exactly sure
um all that said I do appreciate
the video in some ways because it makes
clear for anyone who hasn't been paying
attention that these people really are
full-on pagans I mean this is full-on
paganism this skit really isn't a skit
it's more like uh it's it's like the the
leftist version of a video you might
play for kids at Vacation Bible School
uh it's not supposed to be funny I think
that's why people are confused so this
kind of went viral for all the wrong
reasons you know as far as Apple's
concerned and everyone was sort of
confused and they're saying is this
supposed to be funny What's Happening
Here am I supposed to be laughing and
the answer is no this is an expression
of religious worship more than anything
else when it comes to carrying your
valuables or self-defense items in your
vehicle most people feel they have to
choose between safety and convenience
someone breaking into your car will
typically check the glove box under the
seats in the center console now we can
outsmart them with the headrest safe
which gives you convenience and peace of
mind the headrest saved exactly what it
sounds like you can replace your
standard headrest in your car with their
easy to access safe access to Safe you
just pull the side part off then you uh
can either use your fingerprint use a
key or manually type in the code to open
the save there's no way that anyone
could know your headdress safe is even
there and even if they did there's no
way that they could get it open without
using one of the three methods to unlock
it so it's very safe very secure the
headrest safe has a universe reversal
design that allows it to fit all
vehicles and the best part is these come
in variety of colors to match the
interior of your car I have their black
leather Vulcan headrest for my vehicle
and I love it I took my family out to
dinner a couple weeks ago and the
restaurant only had valet parking well
thanks to my headrests if I was able to
leave valuables in my car that I wanted
to keep extra safe and I had peace of
mind as well depending on the day I'll
put self-defense items cash or
medications in the safe it gives me
peace of mind knowing that it will stay
out of the hands of our kids valets or
Intruders so what are you waiting for
save a hundred dollars today at the
headrestsafe.com with promo code wall
should check out that's the
headrestsafe.com promo code Walsh
we all have a lot on our schedules with
how much we have to do every day but you
can take one big thing off your plate by
putting great meat on your plate with
good ranchers you care about what your
family eats and so does good ranchers
that's why they spent years building
relationships with local farms to Source
the best 100 American beef chicken pork
and now wild caught Seafood too the best
of the land and sea can now get
conveniently delivered to your door
right now they're offering two years of
free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that's a 480 value it's two
years of free high quality ground beef
and a locked in price no other Meat
Company guarantees you 100 American Meat
and a locked in price as well that's
because no one else is good ranchers you
can save on your beef chicken and pork
by locking in your price today every
single Steakhouse quality cut is
individually wrapped and flash frozen to
make Meal Time easy gotta go to
goodranchors.com today use my code Walsh
for 25 off and free ground beef for two
years remember subscribe to any box to
lock in your price on America's best
meat for two whole years as well that's
goodranchers.com today and use my I code
Walsh for over 500 in savings subscribe
to good ranchers American Meat delivered
now it may not be entirely sincere from
Apple since they're a soulless corporate
Behemoth but but that's the idea and
here's what you have to understand uh
what you see in the video is not really
a metaphor
like they really do think of Mother
Nature as an entity as an individual as
a goddess of some kind and for some on
the left an increasing number on the
left this is this is explicit I mean
they are explicitly pagan
for others it's a bit more ambiguous
even to themselves they don't quite
understand how they feel about it but
ultimately they worship nature because
because this is inevitable right
everybody worships something or someone
uh you know you got to Serve Somebody
But as Bob Dylan said and the instinct
to worship is embedded
uh deeply in our human nature
the question is only
whether you will worship the Creator or
the creation
and uh the modern left chooses the
latter
and that's I mean that's maybe more
philosophical than we need to get
because ultimately again this is just
really I mean on the surface this is
just a cringy
uh corporate virtue signal and um at
least Apple maybe we'll say that they
they are Innovative when it comes to the
realm of cringy uh corporate virtue
signalings they are innovating there at
least there's a little bit of innovation
so they've gone farther than most have
so at least they've done that hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there